Cody
I can't even begin to talk about how
insane last night's episode was I have
been saying it all day today it was the
tribal council of the season I I'm not
over it but I do want to start out by
saying I feel like you handled it with
such Grace you're such a Class Act and I
have to talk about when Jesse went to
shake your hand there was a little bit
of a pause But ultimately you know you
gave him that handshake give gave credit
where credit was due but what was going
through your head in that moment as
Jeffy reached for your hand last night
do I choke slam him in the fire do I
kick him do I punch him in the face
um but like you said give credit with
credits too man he I gave him no choice
he did what he had to do
you know I take the high road and and I
respect him as as a player
absolutely now I have to know how did
Jesse manage to get that Idol back from
you because obviously we didn't see it
and I was like there's no way there's
absolutely no way yeah
um
so Carla was you know this was it was a
perfect storm Carla was constantly
wanting to go to tribal council with
Idols in our hands
she was really pushing it and it just
didn't make sense to me like why don't
we go in there and flex like that you
know and Jesse had planted the seed in
my head that hey she may have knowledge
of power
and in my mind it hasn't been played yet
I mean is that something back out here
so between Colorado continuing to ask me
to play the holy that Tribal Council
Jesse putting that seed in my head and
really not asking for it back
made me go who do I trust Carla or Jesse
why I gave it back to you know I gave it
back to Jesse because in my mind that
was our token of trust and I did for
myself then he's gonna say well what is
Cody doing
what is he strategizing now that he took
this from me so
shocks
shocked to say the least
to say the least I'm still shocked
still shocked now looking back at it now
having seen it and even just thinking
about it do you feel more a sense of
betrayal or do you feel look at it as
more in a game sense of like wow that
was a great game move
uh yeah
it's a great game
Choice uh definitely a bit of both when
he played that I remember I was like
dude you're just saying both our ships
you just played yeah I know guess what
you're going home at five
obviously I didn't know
what everybody's doing watching the show
that he had another one to play at five
um
you know for me I wasn't gonna be able
to do that I know
it would have improved my game had I had
gone for him maybe in here but after the
next but I couldn't do it I was I was
freaking gutted after that NECA vote and
I just
my heart wasn't gonna let me do it and
uh I knew coming into this game that my
Aloha spirit and my Island eyes
was giving me something I had to leave
at the door but
I just couldn't do it
I feel yeah I gotcha well let me just
say you're very entertaining to watch on
the screen I loved every single week and
every week that I talked to someone who
was on a jury they said that they had no
idea that you and Jesse were working
together how much you guys are running
the game until after when they got to
the jury so for you did you ever feel
you know you and Jeff you kept saying
that you were running this ship you and
Jeff you were running the ship do you
think that you were making more moves or
did you feel it look at it as more like
an equal partnership like you guys were
in this making moves together
I mean there's no doubt Jesse was a
strategist I mean he he's been studying
the game for a very long time my
Survivor story I applied in October and
I got fast tracked too
today within a year you know so
I knew that he was wise in this game and
um
I would I would give him more credit
than than myself in making some of those
decisions
um
I was very important to it because we
didn't communicate a lot during the days
we would meet for very precise times and
we were getting different information
from different people
because we had different relationships
with them all so without the Ying
there's no Yang no doubt about it but I
was not afraid to go to the end with
Jesse because I felt that I had some
things that I had done that he was
unaware of that I could bring up a final
Tribal Council right telling Coco that
Dwight is a strategist you know bringing
Gabriel on board
knocking Justine out with the sales
thing those were things that I was
comfortable with talking about at the
end that I could
give myself an edge over him and um
we said from the very first day we start
this game we're gonna finish this game
together so yeah it didn't matter as
long as one of us win a million dollars
there you go I see I love the attitude I
love the positivity like I said Class
Act now I have to ask you if your
original plan of getting Carla out would
have happened what would have been your
next move
in my head I'd had this conversation
with Jesse and this was kind of my exit
from him was hey man depending on who
wins the next thing if neither one of us
get a you know an idol at the next
challenge everybody's gonna think I'm
gonna play my idol I'll play for you
and that was my thing to him be like
we're going bro we're going to the end
yeah
and I that allowed me that allowed him
to have an exit right to say okay Cody's
really gonna give me this thing I'll cut
it then and then I'll walk into the
Final Four
where I will just
I will I will pay for myself you know
that's what yeah fine with your idol I
don't know you got to
um but yeah then again I don't know I've
been out of the game and put me back in
the game I might have done it
well like I would love to see you back
in the game is that something you'd ever
if that opportunity came to you would
you do it again
I got some Redemption
you know I got some Redemption that I I
would love to have an avenge too because
my game got short there's no doubt in my
mind I think if I
would have played like a normal Survivor
player whatever just played my idol
there I go into the final four because
Jesse plays his at the same time and now
he becomes the Target because like whoa
where'd this guy get this at he's now
the target Jesse goes I'm in the
phenomenon forward gabler Carla and Cass
all of which have played great games but
I think I could have you know being on
the right side of every vote not getting
any votes I think I had a resume enough
to
to cast a check but this damn coffee and
danishes kept me up all damn night
well I will say I did love that moment
of you dancing with your coffee I was
like I think that's pretty accurate for
a lot of people when they get their
coffee I was like that's accurate now
although just to wrap things up
obviously didn't play out how you wanted
to but again we'd love to see you again
but overall would you say your Survivor
Journey with everything that you hoped
it would be
yeah I mean I didn't hope to have the
Blind Side of the Season uh on that list
but you know I had the opportunity to
get to play that game for a majority of
the time and I get to sit on the jury
and not everybody can say that it's not
because of their gameplay and who they
are as a person or how good they are at
the game it just cars didn't fall their
way there's a lot of chance in this game
and I'm so grateful to have gotten to be
out there for that amount of time to
have played all those challenges and to
have these you know these strategies and
they have them executed and one after
another and have these high fives and
fist bumps it was um a once in a
lifetime maybe not but it was
I had so much fun out there it was so
fun at the end of the day it's a game
and um you know this game of life is a
lot
a lot more important than that game and
I'm just glad that I got to have that
chapter in my life
well as a Survivor fan I'm glad that we
were able to see it unfold so I'm
rooting for you to come back Redemption
for Cody I'm here for it we need to make
it happen